for more on John McCain we're joined by
CBS this morning co-host John Dickerson
John good morning good morning Anthony
John you you spent a lot of time
covering John McCain over the years and
and to what degree is the service that's
gonna be happening this morning a
reflection of what John McCain was all
about well he authored it in in a sense
I mean he asked former President Bush
and Obama to speak at his service and it
tells you two things just those those
two voices one these are people against
whom he ran bitter campaigns and having
covered both of them and heard the
senator himself talk about his opponents
it is not that he said some things that
you cannot repeat in polite company and
felt very and and he was a competitor
and and so let's not mistake the way he
fought those campaigns when they were
done however he tried his best to work
with those two presidents and he became
close to both of them in in very
specific ways so that's part of his
legacy is and anybody who tried to
normalize relations with Vietnam the
country that had held him for five and a
half years that's in keeping with that
but also it's a symbol and it's a it's
very much in keeping with the famous
speech he gave at the end of his career
on the Senate floor talking about
regular order and regular order is
Democrats and Republicans fighting like
heck and then in the end trying to do
the best thing for the country and so
the symbolism of this service is is
meant to match that message and to that
point John he called himself an
imperfect public servant and his ability
to change his mind really struck me I
want to go to that point because I
remember the MLK holiday vote and I
remember that he was against it and yet
he turned around during the 2008
campaign saying we can be slowed as well
to give greatness it's do a mistake I
made I was wrong and eventually realized
it and and and and I'd remind you that
we can all be a little late sometimes in
doing the right thing and dr. King
understood this about his fellow
Americans what did you take about his
ability to change on subjects well it
reminds me a little bit of
Churchill quote which I'll paraphrase
about America which is America always
does the right thing it just takes them
a while to get around to doing it and in
this case McCain and this was true of
the Confederate flag too in South
Carolina he said it was a symbol of
heritage during the the primary there to
keep himself viable within the
Republican ranks after he lost the
primary and the and the run for the
presidency in 2000 he went back down and
said I was wrong and this is something
we don't see much in politics which is
politicians saying they're wrong but
also this was a part of trying to
maintain a standard he believed in
standards of personal conduct and also
institutional conduct that you you tried
to keep the standard and when you fell
you acknowledged it and then tried to
hold that standard up again as opposed
to the political thing which is usually
to do whatever you please and then
redefine the standard so that so that
you don't have to explain yourself he
was very hard on himself as a politician
in public and in private and that's
certainly part of his legacy John you
had an up-close look at him you had a
chance to cover him on the straight talk
express and you had pretty unfettered
access to him from what I understand I
wonder if that exists today or if
there's a politician that you can think
of that as as as accessible as John
McCain was to reporters it doesn't exist
today and it really didn't exist for
McCain in 2008 that was one of the
problems and challenges of his campaign
when you talk to the people who served
with him and his fellow POWs they said
after the war McCain was starving to
learn as much as he could about the war
and just make up for lost time he
retained that energy and that thrust for
his entire life and that's what covering
him on the campaign was like it was one
long rolling conversation and it was all
over the map from literature to film to
stories and and that energy is really at
the heart of my recollections of that
time period and then also on this somber
day it is very important to remember his
wit in the in his five and a half years
in captivity he was the storyteller
they didn't have any other entertainment
and so he would tell stories as we
talked to John fer one of his cellmates
who you know in Christmas he played
Scrooge in
a rendition of a Christmas carol that
storytelling was at the heart of both
his political success in the campaign
and also what he used to do back there
at the back of the bus all right John
Dickerson in Washington with this more
Washington this morning for us thanks so
much John for being with us Joe think
and stay with CBS News throughout the
morning in just about 20 minutes this
show will be abbreviated and we will go
to Washington for a special report on
Senator McCain's memorial service at the
National Cathedral